is the pride of grand valley state
um and now um
right there at the forefront of this
patriots defense that has scored
touchdowns in its last two games has put
the bang thing
now on multiple opponents in a row the
new england patriots are currently the
seventh seed right now after
taking care of business against the
carolina panthers two-time pro bowler
matthew judon here on the rich eisen
show pleasure to chat with you here on
the mercedes-benz vans phone line
matthew how are you sir
hey pleasure's all my
thank you i appreciate that let's get
right into it how is it how is it
feeling right now i mean you've been on
some top-notch defenses in your days in
baltimore
tell me how this feels to you right now
the sense of things for you with new
england matthew
i feel good uh right now uh we just we
we know we playing uh
good ball and we know uh what we got to
do to win games is good continue to play
the way we play
and uh and so if we can do that i think
uh we all put ourselves in the position
to where we want to be uh so we can
reach our goal i hear you and i'll be
honest with you matthew like um i've
i've been around the block a few times
in this nfl world and certainly the
patriots who have made the super bowl
half of the years that nfl network's
been on the air and i've i've seen the
way this works
usually a defense takes a few weeks to
understand the do your job
sense of things certainly when it's put
together through free agency some
crucial parts
how about you matthew the the idea of
the do your job belichick
uh father-son etc mentality for you and
getting used to that
uh
you know
y'all like like you kind of said man we
you you just
hey it take a little bit to know
everybody you know we all haven't been
playing with each other for years and
years but it's some guys on this defense
uh our leaders that's been playing here
for a very long time
uh and
do your job they i think they embody
that and they embrace it they'll try to
do
too much or they'll
they just go out there and always them
and you and you can see it and they play
and they perform it so who are those
guys thank you who are those we i think
we're doing good who are those guys that
you refer to the leaders in that locker
room defensively uh you know like
height high tower
uh uh max
uh you know
uh
you know he came back but uh
but jamie he just uh he's just teaching
the younger guys you know how to play
what type of professional to be and uh
you know just how to be a
a patriot you know it's
it's a lot that go along with it you
know you always got a target on your
back uh you're always going to get
everybody's best shot you know it's
it's a it's a tough
task to have but you know you you rather
you rather have it so it you know like
guys like that and uh you know you can't
forget about lg
lg been around as a team for a couple
years he got a super bowl with him and
so uh it's people it's people on all
three phases and uh from the back end to
the linebackers to the front lines
that's just been around here and embody
what it means to be a patriot yeah mac
being mccourty and lg being lawrence guy
and you so you you used to be the one
targeting the patriots right correct
like you you oh yeah right
you know uh i was i was a
i was a foe for many years for many
years and it was uh
and you know i i have fun you know being
the enemy
yeah
it was a good time but
now uh you know these these guys have
become uh
some good friends uh
you know and uh we just we just going
out there every week
having fun
and uh you know just doing our job but
when we're uh away from the game and
stuff we also talk about uh we also talk
about life you know so uh these guys uh
quickly but become some good friends
and uh just
it's rare to have like you know good
people like that around the league that
had uh
that had so much to set they had so much
success in this league and championships
after championships or whatnot and uh
and they just still down the earth good
genuine people so i'm just blessed to
come in a situation like that
and uh and for them just to accept me
for who i am and then just to let me do
my thing matthew judon here on the rich
eisen show from my perspective i mean i
saw your game in person i was in sofa
stadium a couple weeks ago about eight
days ago now to watch uh your win
against the chargers and uh you know and
i've been obviously you know and it's
not fair to compare him to brady it's
simply not fair to compare anybody to
tom brady
but i'm seeing mac jones run the offense
with efficiency that i have not seen in
a rookie quarterback in a very long time
what is it like been from your
perspective to see
mac jones get uh drafted obviously you
had already been signed and then to this
present day
matthew
uh i think i think uh it's kind of the
same
lines that uh you're seeing you know uh
the efficiency that he has
and uh just
the uh
spirit that he he takes the coaching
with
uh i don't think he i don't think he
ever shows like bad body language or
poor anything and uh and he's just uh he
says young guy willing to win
you know he uh
he's just coming here and he spends
a lot of time in the building you know
he spends a tremendous amount of time
and ability just trying trying to be the
best he can be and i think uh
from all his sacrifice
uh what and what he do off the field is
why he's so good on the field and while
he's uh
he's having that type of year or that
type of efficiency is because he spends
a lot of time in the building
working on that and so when uh
you know he's a rookie he's gonna have
rookie mistakes and rookie throws and
stuff like that but uh he he
tries to minimize minimize that as much
as possible with everything he does with
everything he does practice
uh
you know film study everything he does
he's trying to minimize all that and so
uh you know we all we all respect him
around this building all right you said
a couple things i want to just linger on
a little bit you said the spirit with
which he takes coaching what do you mean
by that
matthew i don't i haven't seen i haven't
seen him mad you know i uh honestly
uh
i'm not with him as much
you know you kind of got to get digging
some offensive guys for that but uh i
haven't seen him mad yet i seen him
upset
that uh he wasn't playing as well but
his anger
hasn't been towards anybody besides
himself and and that's what you like to
see uh
he kind of he kind of not like point
blame at anybody or anything
and even even uh if he do something bad
he'd be like yeah that's my bad or
something like that and we like hey man
we got your back that's what team is for
and so
yeah he a really good uh qb to have qb
one to have and
you know we that's what we got and
that's who we rocking with so and then
the second thing he said matthew jude on
is he's still just a rookie or he's
still a rookie oh does that mean you're
still testing his knowledge of the
alabama fight song or making
no no yeah that's done he he got nah he
he gotta he gotta go through his uh
rookie dudes and what's that uh you know
he got he got to go through his rookie
dudes you're only a rookie once though
so you can't you don't come back the
second year and be a rookie so he you
got to go through his rookie dude but
that's that's offensive stuff man we i
got i got the defensive guys okay so are
you saying that members of the offense
are requiring him to still do
menial tasks and dress certain ways and
carry bags
i don't know what the offensive guys uh
okay you know that's that's that's up to
him you gotta ask uh
a warrior or somebody okay
that's a rule okay all right very good
uh matthew jude on here on the rich
island show how many is it true
there were only three other players at
your pro day in grand valley state is
that true
matthew
three uh yeah so three other players
like uh
they did uh because i went to the
combine i was fortunate enough to go to
the combine correct so i i didn't do i
didn't do any of that testing okay
and then uh
and so so that whole time i was warming
up didn't warm up enough though and so
after after all that testing was
complete and all that good stuff um
uh
it was a couple coaches there and then
they just they just took me through the
ringer man it was
it was uh it was brutal i was out there
by myself
no water because we didn't have like
trainers out there or anything
uh
it was like no water and i was out there
for like another hour and 30 minutes
just doing i did i did every position
every defensive position drills i did db
work i did the line work i did
linebacker work
and
and when you're going through something
like that when you're going through like
the combine process
or whatever and i don't know what where
it is anywhere else
but they was like
come on right now right now like people
don't get tired
and so
and you know i was i was trying to make
my dream
become a reality so i'm just doing it
and everything but i'm dog tired i'm
like
i'm like they working me to the bone but
uh you know i did i got to do it
uh i i never wish it upon anybody else
but
well you you've definitely put in the
hard work and now you've been
literally and figuratively rewarded for
it um and did you is that where you
first met belichick did you meet him
through the combine process
that year and the draft process or no no
no because better check didn't come
but at no point during the process of
the the patriots maybe even looking at
you and interviewing you you never met a
bill until when until just free agency
now coach uh
coach
uh
daley is is his name okay i think
he was uh i think he was the d line or
dc at the time okay and he came he came
he came and worked me out on a private
workout okay so i'm just wondering so
belichick the first time you ever met
him or got to know him or got to sit
down with him was in this free agent
process this past
winter yesterday
i mean besides like playing the game and
him him saying good job or anything or
you know that's that's pretty much the
first time i ever like poked into him i
have a feeling you made a curse more
than anything else with your play with
the ravens i'm sure but he probably was
looking at you across the way saying
maybe just maybe one day so what have
you what have you what have you
been surprised i guess by
being around him in a way you're no
longer uh
part of the enemy you're now in the
building you're part of the patriots is
there anything about him that surprises
you or that you learned that you didn't
know about him matthew jr oh
jessa
just the knowledge of the game like that
he has
you know uh
and uh just
the attention and detail that he goes
about uh his business with and so that's
that's basically it like uh you know he
he loves and knows football
a lot
and
you know that's that's what he uh
that's what he made his money doing and
that's what he's sticking to
and so uh uh just that and then
honestly i think he i think he like kind
of funnier than
uh
you know people people know but
i think he he just
that's kind of like end in the building
thing okay so like you you kind of you
kind of got to get to know knowing this
stuff
but uh you know i'm i'm glad i did man
he uh
he's a he's a great he's a great teacher
and uh you know i think even better
leader of me
you know it's uh
there's a lot of personalities and stuff
that you know you kind of got to deal
with egos and stuff
but i think uh
i think you know he has done it the best
of anybody ever so
i'm uh i'm very grateful that uh
i got to
i get to play for coach uh
yeah so um i guess
is he a joke teller i mean like you got
a good joke
you got one like you got to meet him no
i i've spent with him i i know he's got
a great sense of humor i've been around
the man i'm just like you know um i'm
just saying does he tell a joke to you
guys or is he uh you know it's just like
when he when he's speaking and stuff
like kind of team wise
uh and we're going over some stuff
you know
it's a tough game okay it's a tough game
and it's a long season so uh you know he
he makes light of some some stuff that
we all find humory
i think that he might okay
so like you see he circles bosa and
calls him bofa is that what you're
saying
[Laughter]
but he all made fun of players
you know he's just just like stuff so
okay oh and so i'm just like i said i'm
just grateful that
i i'm able to be a part of his you know
legacy
uh matthew judon let's do this again i
really enjoyed the chat here uh congrats
on um on the way things are going right
now and the way that uh this trajectory
of this team appears to be pointed
thanks for the call appreciate it yeah
thank you so much you bet that's matthew
judon
of the new england patriots hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here